the Jacobi smog the former business
secretary who joins us now thank you so
much for being on the program
um it was we should see next first real
test at The Ballot Box at the local
elections and we heard from Grant chaps
who said that the mood in the party is
one of Steely determination do you think
that they really those around Russia
because allies really grasped the scale
of the challenge
well it's obviously difficult when a
party's been in office for 13 years but
Richie sunac has been getting on with
business the local election results are
often bad for incumbent governments they
were bad for Tony Blair and he then went
on to win majorities they were terrible
for Margaret Thatcher who then went on
to win very big majorities so I wouldn't
read too much into local elections
I think it's fair not to read too much
into local elections but are you
seriously saying that Russia's unic
could be like Margaret Thatcher on his
way to win a big majority of their next
election
come on
well we'll have we'll have to wait and
see I think politicians we all love
looking at elections and opinion polls
and forecasting what's going to happen
and all these sorts of things
but they are in some ways a distraction
from policy and what I think is
interesting and what yesterday was about
and what the netcon conference tomorrow
is about is developing conservative
thinking and policy what should we be
doing that will make people's lives
better and that's where the retained EU
law bill was so important not as a totem
of your skepticism but how do we make
the economy better for consumers by
cutting prices through supply side
reforms by getting rid of regulations
that make things more expensive for
people and failing to do that has been a
great mistake of the business and trade
Department
interesting because of course this was
your bill when you were a business
secretary meant to see thousands of EU
laws scrapped by the end of the year at
the same time the institute for
government said that policy reality has
finally prevailed over political
rhetoric and the bill was a poison brief
from her gung-ho predecessors most
notably Jacob Reese mark
so you cut off briefly at the end of the
quotation but the institute for
government is
um effectively the junior Ganymede
equivalent for civil servants the junior
gangnamed was the club that Jeeves
belonged to as I'm sure your viewers all
know
um so I would only expect them to come
out and give the line of the Civil
Service we've been very idle about this
need to have worked harder but what
we've got to understand is the point of
getting rid of Return To You law it's
not about
um Whimsical you're a skepticism it's
about making the economy better whilst
we're in an inflationary period one of
the ways to bring down prices is by
tightening monetary policy in the
government the bank of England's doing
that and that's difficult for people the
other thing you can do that brings
prices down is free up the economy from
over regulation and this is product
regulations this is the reach
regulations
this is making it easier for people to
trade and do business and that's such a
missed opportunity particularly in
environment it's the so-called supply
side reforms that we have long needed
so you're really saying you mentioned
Jeeves there are you really saying that
it's just civil servants who are
effectively blocking this and that
Russia senior can come in beta knock
about that is that what you're really
saying
well Grant traps was confident whilst um
he was business secretary that it could
be done I was confident that it could be
done and it seems to me there's been a
considerable lot of impetus in the last
three months partly possibly because of
the reorganization of the department
I want to talk to you about taxes as
well because this is something that came
up an awful lot yesterday and how
concerned are you about the current rate
of tax because people around me she seem
like saying look at the minute we've got
to try and get inflation down and
actually that's the best tax cut that
anyone can have
well oddly I don't think I particularly
disagree with Rishi sunak on tax and
spend but I would be perhaps more
hawkish on spending I think the state is
spending too much we're up at 47 of GDP
we can't afford that level that's why
we've got the highest level of tax in 70
years I'm not in favor of unfunded tax
cards but I am in favor of reducing the
size of the state making sure the money
the state spent is better spend and
they're lying for tax cuts that way and
I think that's a matter of priority the
state is doing too much so where do you
think the spending cuts should fall
where should they fall well you've
certainly got to look at the Civil
Service that when I was
um in the cabinet office we had a plan
to reduce the civil service by 91
000. I think we should cut things like
hs2 which are a terrible white elephant
you you begin to find there are many
billions to be saved once you save the
billions uh you are able to give people
their own money back that's the thing to
remember there's no such thing as
government money it's all taxpayers
money and the government should only
take from taxpayers the minimum that is
necessary to provide the services that
are required and do you think Russia
gets that
but I doubt he would disagree
particularly with that view of
conservative values
the it's no good being holier than now
if you end up behaving like a boudia I'm
no historian right I have no idea what a
Bulger is so what border what do they
behave like
oh well actually there's a very
interesting revisionist biography of
Pope Alexander VI which indicates that
he wasn't as bad as history has thought
in so perhaps the borders aren't as bad
as all that
um what I was saying was the Prime
Minister gave a very clear promise on
the return just to come in if I may if I
may what what do they do what were they
known for
oh those are Borges nepotism and all
sorts of carry-on going on there's a
very good kind of carry-on what kind of
carry on all sorts I I I I suggest you
read the relevant books
genuinely
you talked about it
as I say there's a revisionist biography
on PayPal Alexander you might want to
read that too but the point I was making
was that you can't put out campaign
video with the shredder working full
speed about uh overheat getting rid of
EU laws and then break that promise
that's the key that promises that are
given by politicians ought to be stuck
to particularly when they're that clear
and specific
reference to
the book they do and everyone knows
about the Borges everyone knows about
the borders but as I say people have
different views why would you tell us
what they did then if everyone knows
about them
history lecture
if I'm happy with the reference but if
people want history lectures I'll give
them on GB news through eight and nine
o'clock every Monday to Thursday
okay you've got your reference in there
tell us what the said what did
they do
educate me the the the the borders paper
Alexander VI was a Spaniard who became
paper at the end of the uh 15th century
um he'd been in the curia for for many
years he was very unpopular with
um a lot of the Italians who didn't want
to have a Spanish Pope
um and his successor but one
um indicated that he had done all sorts
of things he probably hadn't done
including having children which for Pope
is unusual
um he was certainly nepotistic he
certainly appointed
his nephews to important posts within
the curia and he may have been poisoned
at the end of his life it's not entirely
clear there's a sort of brief Canter
through the history of the borders which
I must confess I wasn't expecting to be
talking about this morning
so corrupt effectively is that what
you're really referencing to Rishi
Scenic no I think you're the you're
delving into this far too much now I
didn't think um he was corrupt but I
think he broke a promise
that was the point
was it a mistake to get rid of Boris
Johnson in your view
I mean of course it was I've said that a
million times but it would be an even
bigger mistake now to get rid of Rishi
sunak conservative people cannot keep on
changing leaders we we must back the
leader we have got
so no support let me be clear about that
and I said this at the conference
yesterday the CDO conference
um that the Tory party would be toast if
we change leader again and therefore we
need to support the leader we've got but
but that doesn't mean we agree with him
on every policy and to have a debate
about policy is important and I hope
interesting for conservative members in
the country at Large
and now just finally you of course used
to be the brexit opportunities Minister
now we've got someone on later you've
probably heard of him as a Campbell you
know he's no fan of brexit and I'm sure
he's going to be very vocal in giving us
all of the reasons why brexit has been a
big disaster so help me out what would
you come back to him on to say these
have been the benefits of leaving the
European Union
okay well we saved 191 billion pounds
191 billion pounds by not being in the
EU for its covered Recovery Fund that
would have been our share of the eu's
Recovery Fund 191 billion that's one
thing
um what else we've got a free trade deal
uh with Australia which will be much
better than the forecasts uh predict we
were able to show Global Leadership uh
over Ukraine and Putin would probably
have invaded Ukraine successfully if the
UK had been banned in by the requirement
of sincere cooperation and had had to
follow a franco-german line in dealing
with Russia which is what we did in
2014. so those are three huge benefits
cash benefit to British British
taxpayers so you genuinely believe that
Putin would have successfully invaded
Ukraine if the UK had been part of the
EU
I think the leadership trained by Boris
Johnson which he could only do because
he was not bound by sincere cooperation
in short that a coalition was set up
that made it impossible for Putin to
succeed and I think if that hadn't been
the case we'd been bound by this concept
of sincere Corporation we'd have had the
Mucky compromise that would um delivered
in 2014 when Russia invaded the Crimea I
think it's really important but above
all of this we've got democracy so we
can decide how we're governed rather
than having to do what we're told by
Aleister Campbell's mates
I'll put that to him thank you very much
uh indeed Jake every Smog on the program
today great pleasure thank you